[Music]
hi I'm Mike house raske and I'm here at
cube con EU in Copenhagen walking the
show floor and here with J frog right I
am Raj
I'm with the G frog and take care of
technology alliances in partnership and
take care of the Google partnership for
the last year or so that's great how how
does a J frog work with gke so we have
been very closely tied with GK and we
have our instances running on GK I mean
artifactory is provided as a as a
product on GK and we also are providing
the kubernetes registry now as part of
our contribution to the community and
this is something which we have been
involved in the last couple of years as
part of the development of the
kubernetes registry as de facto registry
for implementing kubernetes clusters
that's great so if a customer wants to
use J frog it's super easy for them to
go find it and what do they do
absolutely it's it's basically available
on GC p as a SAS offering and we also
support the gracias
cat form and that is the most important
part because our products our cafes API
the x-ray product as a graph is API
which works seamlessly with the
platform and we also are very closely
working with orbiter and all over this
is our you know test platform nobody if
anybody wants to take a test drive on J
frog products you can use orbit around
can use orbit era and we provide a free
instance on orbiter which there is a
there is a set up there where people can
go in and play with different products
and also also experience how GCP works
alright so if I want to test it out go
check out orbit era yes anything else
about the Google partnership with J frog
you want to touch on yeah I mean Google
is one of our premier partners and we
have been working very closely on Graff
ears on proven it is as a contributor
and also now helm repository thousand is
something which we have been using very
closely and that is now available on GPS
well thank you so much Raj thank you
Thanks and thanks all for joining us
that keep Connie you have a good one